i think it might be cool to see kind of
like another story featuring an evil
devil goat or just this devil goat
wandering the countryside or the whole
movie is just an evil devil
you're describing goat simulator right
now
i am yeah well there you go
hi today we're talking about horror
villain origin stories that we want to
see on screen
and uh yeah this is a tough one for a
lot of reasons
because part of what makes a horror
movie villain so good sometimes is not
knowing
sort of what makes them who and what
they are and a lot of times kind of like
giving giving some
information
some backs too much backstory can kind
of let let a lot of the air out of the
balloon and kind of take the mystery and
the menace and the scary stuff away do
you guys agree when i understand this
thing
yeah yeah because i mean we've talked
about this on the show before like the
the the prequel curse right i mean
sometimes it really works and then other
times you're like i don't i didn't want
to know that stuff yeah i don't care how
han solo got his jacket
right i don't care how wolverine got his
jacket right
and mystery in a horror movie is so
important like i don't care i don't care
how anyone got their jackets
a lot of jacket-related origin stories
about it until just prequels are very
serious
i mean like it makes sense that there
would be a lot of drama beyond getting a
new one yeah how did loki get his hat
that's what i want to know nobody knows
there's a question
um but there's all kevin feige
yeah you imagine he had one of those
guys bicycles and then he like he
crashed it so hard that his head kind of
just the handlebar stuck
oh
there's a few on here that are are
interesting to think about on this list
on looper.com uh the few that i
responded to because i'm not a big
horror guy but i've seen a few the
facility from the cabin in the woods
that could be interesting that could be
a fun kind of i actually did like that
one
cabin in the woods scared the living
daylights out of me i didn't sleep for
like a week yeah
i'm a baby i'm sorry i should get that
out of the way i'm a huge horror baby
it's comedy horror movie for children no
here's
here's the thing though i was okay with
cabin in the woods until i think the
thing that broke me was the ballerina
with the teeth of face or the face
i think that really like that stuck in
my brain and it and it ruined me for a
little while i was okay with a lot of it
and then the monster explosion at the
end i was like i don't like this
that's really fair because sometimes all
it takes is one image one
disturbing thing to set you off like a
thing i really don't like is body horror
i don't like like when things move
weirdly or incorrectly that really
frightens me so like yeah body horror
too much i can't i can't do it that i
felt that way when i i saw the ring in
theaters and that like
yeah that one got like that stuck in my
brain for a while and it's i sleep with
a tv
in my room i can never watch the ring
ever because i have a television in my
room and i would just never sleep again
maybe it would break you of having a tv
in your room whatever
you just don't know me
so anyway cabin in the woods would be an
interesting one because maybe i can even
envision it like sort of like a rotating
like a like a tv series a prequel series
it's just those two guys
um just do it going about their day job
and
scaring people killing people
sacrificing to the great god whatever
whatever the plot turned out to be
spoilers for cabin in the woods
spoilers for all these movies i'm sorry
we're going to put a list of all the
movies that we're going to talk about
now after cabin in the woods right
here
[Music]
okay so if you don't want those movies
spoiled potentially you can click away
now by the way leave a like thank you
very much um so
[Laughter]
other movies on this list nina i know
you've seen the orphan or orphan as it's
called a long time ago
it's more of a like a thriller than a
heart a few of the ones on the list are
more like thriller style which is
something i really like
um
i like to i like the thrill of like to
be scared by tension rather than like
boo
it's a scary ghost thing um
which i think is like what the conjuring
is i don't know yeah
it's a scary ghost thing thank you so
orphan has one of the most bonkers
twists in movie history where like these
people adopt a very weird child and
she's being very weird and violent and
murdery and it turns out that she is an
adult who has a disease that makes her
look like a little kid and she also um
engaged in in
in a uh a career that
one would not want a child to be in i
don't know how to say this in this video
without getting flagged kind of
in in a fashion so um you can look it up
just go look it up it's pretty weird
it's pretty messed up um and so it turns
out it's grown up a cro a grown-up party
facilitator
great perfect uh and it turns out she's
like just been
trying to like they just have this 33
year old kid in their house
who's like trying to murder them and i i
just love you know what go for it right
if you're gonna have a twist make it as
weird as possible swing swing hard we'll
see how it goes it didn't go great but
it wouldn't be ambition
wouldn't it be a ballerina it would be
about her right because she i think they
adopt her from
oh my god i don't know what country just
put it below me now i don't remember
where but yeah
i haven't seen that movie since it like
came
yeah i guess it would be about her i
think that
actually would probably be fine except
you'd have to get the original actress
or someone who looks exactly like her i
don't know how that would work
but tough show that feels like that
actually feels like something that they
would make considering you know didn't
they do an annabelle prequel or spin-off
from the conjuring film so this doesn't
feel that out of the realm of
possibility to be honest it could happen
it could work
it would ruin the twist of the of the
movie though of the actual movie right
but
i mean i think most horror sequels
though yeah but this is an origin story
yeah it's a prequel i don't know
all i can think of at this point all i'm
thinking of is how dumb is this idea and
you can tell me right now should a
sequel to orphan be called morphin
first off
it's not here's a bag of cash
i think you hit the nail right on the
head i think you scratched that society
didn't know it had wait wouldn't the
prequel to orphan be called i have
parents
well sure i was saying
yeah
parents parents would be better just
call parents
awful parents
it's just five minutes of someone being
dropped off at an orphanage that's the
whole movie um
other other ones on here
like again and i'm just gonna kind of
scratch the surface for a few more of
these like red from us
it's an interesting idea
i liked a lot of us until the end
explanation where it kind of goes into
the world building that created this
situation these doubles and that's where
it lost me so i feel like
while i would be interested to see how
they could make it work i also
inherently don't think the premise
the underlying world of us worked that
well for me so i'll say that i'd want to
see an origin story for red from us if
for no other reason than to give that
that film a chance to kind of redeem
where it lost me in the first one
and then the only other one on here that
i kind of want to dive into a little bit
more uh is the overlook hotel from the
shining which i thought would be was a
really interesting idea yeah i don't
know like the the creepy hotel that
makes people nuts in the shining
what's that place's story that's an
origin story that i think would not
necessarily take away
from the power that it has in the
shining and i think that you could again
you could set it you know as a series
make it make it this really interesting
terrifying creepy place that
terrifying creepy things happen i don't
know i don't well and maybe at the very
end of it like uh grady shows up like
that's when like the movie ends when
like he arrives the guy who that's
that's the guy who kills his family
before
um the torrance is right grady
guys come on um
no but i mean like because that's what
it's like i don't remember anything
when when jack and his family show up at
the overlook at first like the
proprietor whose name i definitely don't
remember is like oh yeah the last family
who stayed here uh the husband went
crazy and he killed his family anyway
here are the keys have fun and it's like
very weird that he tells him that um and
so i'm imagining like a cool sequel
would be like yeah like how the overlook
like kind of gets its you know how it
came to be so haunted but then like the
last shot is the the previous jack
torrance showing up with his with his
twin daughters those are the daughters
that he uh he kills yeah um and his
giant his giant
elevator full of blood he pulls that up
he found room for it in the u-haul he
could bring it with him it's fine
it's just a u-haul filled with blood
it's a little
trailer
don't open them up
yeah
be careful of the buckets
so one that i thought that might be
interesting and again i'm not a big
horror guy so like i apologize right off
the top that that i'm starting this
video off with just being like i don't
know what i'm talking about which is
fine because what's the difference um uh
black philip from the witch
are you familiar with the witch either
of you didn't see the witch
um so
the witches are way above my horror pay
grade in terms of people it's not even
it's not it's again that's that's more
of a of a tension kind of thing it's
okay
but it's like
mounting dread
um yeah
but um i'm gonna spoil it okay i've
probably read the wikipedia entry it's
fine
black philip is is the goat that is on
their farm that the two creepy little
kids and the family they like sing songs
about and they're like we're talking to
black phillip black phillip is is you
know he's gonna get you or whatever it
turns out that black philip is in fact
an embodiment of the devil
and eventually seduces our lead
character into witchcraft um which is
anya taylor joy's debut right yeah that
means she's amazing
she's amazing and everything yeah she's
so good
so but yeah i don't know like i think it
might be cool to see kind of like
another story featuring an evil devil
goat or just this devil goat wandering
the countryside or the whole movie is
just an evil devil yeah you're
describing goat simulator right now
i am yeah
there you go
i actually
i'd love to go to me later as a prequel
to that i want to see the babadook's
origin story for that same reason
because i want to see how the babadook
became a queer icon
moves to a big city gets wrapped up in
like a lot of scene stuff that he's now
really ready for yeah yeah he goes to
his first pride parade he's like wow i
love this whole atmosphere yeah
it's just the smell he's going to go
baba dork
um
but tom what what do you think what are
some horror villain origin stories that
you'd like to see
brian i'm really glad that you brought
up uh the orphan earlier because
it's just orphan
the character from the i apologize
you're right that's breezier thank you
zuckerberg that's drop of the it's
cleaner
i'm glad that you brought it up uh the
the the villain from that is actually
really similar to one of my favorite
horror villains uh of all time uh
another like
seemingly innocent uh
kind of quirky female presence that gets
brought into this this familial setting
and it turns out that the whole thing is
this lie and that
uh lucy from while you were sleeping i
would love to find out
why it is
that she's alone at the holidays why
what happened to her family apparently
her whole family died how'd that happen
i like while you were sleeping i like
this movie i do too i think it's a
really effective piece of uh
horror i think that it's it's
it's a terrifying proposition
no i agree with what you were what you
were saying earlier i think that i think
that most of the time horror
characters are
either mysterious like spooky or uh
they're metaphors and that
explaining more about either of those
things doesn't make them more scary or
more effective you know the the cabin in
the woods i think that the facility is
it's a it's a metaphor for horror movies
right like that's the idea yes
i don't know i i love the idea of like
an anthology series where we explore
this place but like overall
getting more explanations
that doesn't make it that doesn't make
it a more effective scary thing right
right i'm rambling please continue
that's okay that's all this is
yeah
we have fun
we have fun nina yeah yeah
now that now that tom has effectively
trolled me in my enjoyment of a classic
sandra bullock romance that was great i
thought he was going to steal my pick so
i i'm very what's your pick i would
never steal your pig
i was so sure
because you were describing a seemingly
innocent woman drawn into a familial
situation only to reveal that she is
sinister and i okay i want to preface
this by saying that i don't actually
necessarily want this movie idea to
happen i'm just saying if it got
greenlit i probably would go see it um
so one of my favorite movies not just
horror movies but like any movie is is
get out i love get out very very much
sure i
saw it in theaters i probably watched it
upwards of 500 times i it's just it's
it's perfect it's such a good movie from
beginning to end it's a really
really good movie and i i don't want a
prequel to it but if it had to happen i
would want it to go all the way back to
when the armitage family started doing
this
i don't want the prequel to be about
like rose i don't want it to be like
rose hunts for for men to steal or
people rather um but i want to go back
to like the grandparents and why this
even came into their minds like if if i
am gonna see a villain origin story
from a horror movie that i love
and i and it had to happen i think that
would be the only kind of
thing i could handle again i don't like
we've talked about so many of these it
would take away so much of the cool
stuff and get out and and it would also
prevent like daniel cool you from being
involved or alison williams or any of
the phenomenal cast members but
if somebody was going to
capitalize off of get out success
that's the only way i can see it even
vaguely working
so that's my
submission
do you know what i would call a prequel
an origin story to get out come in
yeah
parent
[Music]
none of us have any good car ideas
and old
uh
yeah i don't know horror movie i mean
again like the one that i keep going
back to is because it's one of the only
horror movies that i've actually watched
is the thing but like do i want to see
an origin story of this horrible alien
demon not really
like i'm curious
but
probably not like a ton of story to tell
right like it's it's yeah it's a ball of
goo
and alien comes to earth like why did it
leave
right is it the hero of i don't know it
had religions
how did it get its jacket
[Music]
how did the thing get its jacket
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]